おお
わかるよ　一人って
楽だもん
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
はいというわけでついに5月が終わり6月になってしまいました
すいません質問コーナーもう少し待ってくださいってう話と
ちょっとあのーこの人間関係っていう話について
今日はちょっと皆さんに
いじめについてお話ししようと思います
とりあえず皆さんいじめにあった人ってどれくらいいますか
ってかいじめってやばくね　普通に萎えるんだけど
いじめあった人結構いると思うっす　てかなんかねもう
いじめってどこでもあるんで　なんか知らぬ間にいじめになってたり
いじめって思ってないのにいじめしてたりしてたみたいなパターンがあったりするんで
ちょっと一概にうまく言えないんですけど
ちょっと今日はそのいじめについてちょっと僕の実体験ふまえて話してみようと思います
あの少なくとも僕はですね　えー人生で過去
2回はいじめにあっております
だいぶ前の話なんですけどね
まぁなんか人間関係っていう点ではなんかいじめも結局なんか似たようなもんなんで
まぁ多分世の中には僕以上にひどい思いをしてる人がたくさんいると思うので
人間関係とかでね
まぁ僕の例を出しちゃなんなんですけども
まぁちょっと僕が過去にあったことを
ちょっとみなさんに…
簡単に
できるだけコミカルにお話ししようと思います
最初に僕がいじめにあったのは
5歳の時だったかなぁ
待ってちょっと聞いてみよう
俺のかーちゃんが覚えてんだよね俺がいじめにあったの確か
ﾌﾟﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙ
うわ
多分僕の記憶が正しければ確か初めていじめにあったのが5歳の時ですね
僕実は…
こう見えて
習い事で
ハッ
小さい時の物覚えがめちゃくちゃいいんで
なんか習い事をさせようってことで
最初空手をやらせてもいらいました
やっぱこういざましく強くなろうかなって思って
空手を始めたんですけど
まぁそれが5歳の時でまぁ初日にその体験会みたいな
空手これから始めるんでちょっと1回見に行ってみましょうみたいな感じで
もう空手の道場に行ってもう色んな人たちと混じって
こうやってハッハッってこうやってたわけですよ
まぁ風を斬るレベルでね
ってこでとて空手をハッハッってやってたんですけども
もう初めてで緊張しててもう他の人も知らない人だらけだったんですけど
僕のイメージだとやっぱすごい怖い人が多かったなと思いましたなんか
うわーこれ喧嘩強そうだなーみたいな人が多くて
実際はわかんないすけど当時の僕のイメージはそんな感じでした
初日の空手のレッスンが終わって
終わりでーす片付けしましょーって
なんか掃除したり色々掃除してたんですけど
僕初めてでこうなんか用具室
なんか掃除用具とか置くところに最後まで残って
このへっへって片付けしてたんですけど
片付けしてる時になんか
うわっ記憶が正しければもう10歳とかかな
小学生のなんか怖そうなお兄ちゃんが
僕が中にいるのに用具室の鍵をかけてきて
まじで結構長い時間出れなかったんですよ
なんか助けてって言っても全然聞いてくれないし
もうなんか知らない人だらけだしもう助けを求められようがないですよ
かーちゃんの迎えが来てたのか知らないんですけど
もういきなり初見でね1発目でいきなりいじめられて
っていうのかあってもう帰ってすぐかーちゃんに
あの空手でいじめられたよって言って
もうその日で空手を辞めました
僕の空手人生終了です　ありがとうございました
っていうのがまず1発目だったかなあ
でも5歳だったからもうほぼ記憶にないんですけど
なんかめちゃくちゃ怖かった記憶があります
助けを求めようにも誰のいないからね初めてだと
っていうのがまず昔1個ありましたね
で、次がなんですけどえー時を遡り小学6年生の時でございます
えー僕もだんだん成長してきて
結構身長が高くなったんですよ
もう学年でトップ2かトップ3ぐらい身長が高くなってて
で、あのーやっぱ小学校からちょいちょいあるんすよね
あのーカースト制度というか
グループがあるんすよねあのこの一番人気の男子、女子グループみたいな
一軍の一番そのなんか目立ってる男子のグループの中の
下っ端にいたんですずっと小学校の頃から
そんな超やんちゃでもなかったんでなんかそいつらにとりあえず
ついてってたみたいな感じだったんですけど
まぁなんかうちの小学校ですね
僕が小学6年生の時に
なんかプールを新しく作ろうっていうことで
新しくプールを作ったんですよ
めちゃくちゃ綺麗なやつ
で、新しいプールを作ってそれの
なんかオープニングセレモニーみたいな
なんか開会式っていうわけじゃないんですけど
なんか新しいプールができたのでみんなで祝いましょうみたいな
式がなんか意味不明なのがあって
で、それになぜが僕が選ばれて
開会の言葉を
なん、な、な、あいつなんで俺にやらせたんだよ
ふざけんじゃねー
なんかそのプールができましたこれから大切に使いますみたいなセリフを
なぜが俺が言うことになって
そういうの絶対断れないタイプだったんで
「はい、わかりました」っていて受けたんですけど
なんかその頃から一軍の中のなんか
空気がちょっと変わり出してきてて
なんかそれが原因かわかんなかったんですけど
すっげー避けられるようになってきて
もうやばいっすよもうなんか
うまく例えれないけどもうなんか今までの全然対応が違うってか
俺が近寄ったらみんなこうやってさーどっか行くみたいな
俺が来たら行くみたいな
キモいとかバカとか言われるタイプのいじめじゃなくて
もう本当にただただ避けられると言うか
もうシャットアウトされて一切関係を絶たれるみたいな状態が続いて
そういう日が何日か続いて
そのままもうプールの開会式になってしまいました
生徒代表　江田君
あ、僕の本名ですよ
生徒代表江田君誓いの言葉みたいなのをお願いしますみたいな感じで
頑張ってこう覚えて心がもうズタボロだったんすけど
覚えて挨拶を言ったわけですよ
プールみんなで大事に使います　おなしゃっす
みたいな感じで言い終わった時に
本来だったら多分拍手が起きるはずだったんですけど
生徒の方を見るともう
シーンってなってなーっていう
記憶が正しければそうだった気がします
まずあれ先生気付かなかったのかなって今なら思うんですけど
うーんなんかもうこの時から　この時だったら
もうなんかね親に言えなくて恥ずかしくて
なんかいじめられてるつったらなんかすごいナメられそうだったんで
なんか恥ずかしくて親にも言えなかったで
そのままもう堪えたまましばらく過ごしていたんですけど
まぁ唯一の救いだったことが
このいじめ期間が結構短くて
なんかもう2週間ぐらいしたら
結構普通になんか戻ってきちゃったりして
なんかしばらく経ったらみんな普通に仲良くなってくれたんですけど
なんでだろうなぁもう本当にただただ一人で
寂しくしてた気がしますねその2週間は
多分ね根はいい奴らだったんすよ友達が小学校の時の
多分みんなでやめようって言ったのかわかんないんすけど
ほんとぼっちでしばらくいたんで
なんかそれを見て多分やめようって誰かが言ってくれたのかもしんないし
なんか必然的に自然に戻ったのかもしれないです
まぁわからないんですけど僕は過去そういう
2回いじめを受けてきておりました実は
ってか空手もやってました
ハッ
んーわかんないんすけどこういうの経験したんで
中学、高校はねなんか割と誰かとつるむのを
あんまり避けるようにしてましたね
部活くらいがななんか特定の友達で
こうがっと輪を作っちゃうと
そこからはぶられた時もうどうしようもなくなっちゃうんで
部活の奴らとは仲良かったんですけど
中学、高校はなんかこう
すげー仲良いグループみたいなのは作らず
比較的1人か2人で行動してた気がしますね
闇ですね
俺6月の最初に何言ってんだ
なんか人間関係っていうワードを聞いて
あぁそういうのがあったなーと思ってちょっと話してみました
いじめで困ってる人すごい多いと思うんですけど
う〜ん
まぁいじめはもう絶対起きます
もう何が何でもどんないいやつだろうといじめは起きます
だってみんな違う人間ですもん
多分ねみんなね同じ人間、同じ性格、 同じなんか容姿とかだったら
絶対いじめは起きないと思うんですよみんな同じなんで
けどそれはもうありえなくて
もう色んな性格の人、色んな顔の人、色んな容姿の人
色んな人がいるから
それでこうなんか誰がか劣ったり
誰かをおとしめやすかったりする状況ができちゃうんで
いじめが起きちゃうんでもういじめが起きるのはしょうがないと
いじめゼロは無理
あ　こっちですね
いじめゼロは無理ですね100パーセント
いじめてるって人が自覚を持って
やめていくしかないと僕は思っています
なんでちょっといじめしてるなって自覚あるあなた
もうちょっと昔の記憶しすぎて申し訳ないんすけど
僕はすごい嫌な思いをしたんで
もう自分がいじめてるなって思う人は
もうやめてあげてほしいなって思います
やべーなんか寂しくなってきちゃった
いじめの話してると寂しくなってきちゃった
いやーマジね親にも言えないすからね
恥ずかしくていじめられてるなんて
うーんいじめられてる人いたら
もうなんか立ち向かうのも辛いし
いじめられてる人がやめてくれる保証もないんで
本当にもうねどうしようもなく苦しいんだったら
僕は正直に逃げてもいいと思います
僕は空手の道場の時に秒で逃げたんで
逃げるが勝ちっす
っていう感じでですねちょっと人間関係っていう言葉を聞くと
そういうのを思い出したんでちょっと話してみました
みなさんはいじめられた経験ありますか？
いや結構辛いんすよね
っていうわけでみんないじめないように気をつけよう
じゃーなっ
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング　しんみりVer.】